I ran into the golf game The Bachelor
headed to Costa Rica on Monday night but
it wasn't all roses for a Peter Weber
get it
roses anyway The Bachelor and the
remaining women traveled to Central
America for the three-hour yeah you
heard me
the read our episode and we finally
learned more about the freak accident
that landed pilot Pete in the hospital
there was a ton of blood it looked like
a murder scene here's what went down
Pete arrived in the country before the
ladies and all hell broke loose after
his head collided with a golf cart and
then the glass he was holding in his
hand I ran into the golf game and I had
a glass in my hand as I hit my head I
then shattered the glass in the head and
is like a freaking stabbed myself in the
head I have 22 stitches I will never
forget this experience be reminded it is
but Peters bloody injury was far from
the most dramatic thing to go down in
Costa Rica the ladies head out on a
group date to pose for Cosmopolitan
magazine and whoever wins the challenge
gets to be on the mag's March cover well
Victoria app goes in for a full-blown
makeout sesh
and she wins the whole thing but like
how awkward oh and a little follow up on
Victoria FS Cosmo cover and a letter
posted on Kosmos website monday they
explained that they decided not to run
it after photos surfaced of Victoria
posing in white lives matter clothing an
inset of the cover has already been
published in the mags March issue
alongside the accompanying fashion shoot
but will not appear on their website
cosmos editor-in-chief explained quote
unequivocally the white lives matter
movement does not reflect the values of
the Cosmo brand we stand in solidarity
with black lives matter and any cause
that fights to end injustice 'as for
people of color et has reached out to
ABC and Warner Brothers the company
behind the bachelor for comment but back
to all that drama Peter and Kelly go on
a one-on-one peter questions their
connection but ultimately gives her a
rose and of course there was the gift
that keeps on giving
Tammy and Kelsey drama she cries every
second day and her like escape to
dealing with emotions and like hard
times to drink she's probably the most
insecure girl I've ever met in my life
and right now who knows what she's doing
of course you can count on ET to keep
bringing you all the latest from this
season of The Bachelor so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]